welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Star Wars Episode nine the rise
of Skywalker has been blanketing us with
near daily TV spots and
behind-the-scenes featurettes so let's
review all the new clues that are tucked
into each of these promos and take a
risk of discussing a star war without a
hashtag baby oda in it boiler warning in
case of a speculation reveals too much
now i have not read any of the rumoured
plot leaks because i consider that to be
cheating in this game that only i seem
to be sticking to the rules of let's
start with the promo spot titled end
we've done all this time are you doing
their promo extends the footage of three
POS apparent farewell whether via
interfacing with a ship or a rebooting
memory wipe of some sorts he now says oh
we've done all this time signaling to me
that he could be reliving past and
present simultaneously maybe even
memories before the memory wipe at the
end of the prequels we also hear the
notes of Rey's theme during all this
each of these spots features a different
one of John Williams compositions we'll
get to another big one later there are
also shots of Rey and kylo in that white
room that we've seen them in before
looking upon that burnt mask of Darth
Vader right before they shatter the
pedestal and we get a better look at
kylos reassembled helmet it's broken
shards fused together forming these red
streaks not unlike the black tattoos on
the red skin of Darth Maul keep that in
mind for later there's another shot of
Rey facing kylo both their lightsabers
drawn and what looks like a blizzard
covered ruins maybe from the ice planet
we've seen other shots of there are open
flames all about suggesting this is like
mid-battle into the distance behind Rey
you can make out another figure
approaching them perhaps one of the
Knights of Ren or a first-order officer
and one more shot before we move on Rey
leaps from the deck of a space station
bay to the departing Falcon which blows
back all the stormtroopers but not ray
or kylo implying that they're using the
force to keep their ground using the
Falcon this way calls back the way han
blasted back the smugglers in the force
awakens on to the next Primeau spot
titled feet this promo gives us one of
our best yet looks at the nights of
rinse scanning the surrounding area from
a cliff on the new desert planet of
personna there's also a shot of kylo
with a saber
through a resistance soldier on that
ashy forest location that we've seen him
in before another footage he reaches out
his hand perhaps performing a kind of
forced push we'll see
this is actually a flashback to an
earlier period maybe it's before he rose
up through the ranks of the first order
and in the midst of this battle imagery
there's a brief shot of the new red
armored Sith troopers now among all
these promos have been two
behind-the-scenes featurettes that
reveal some of the interesting cameos
we'll be getting lin-manuel Miranda
appears scene in some kind of resistance
uniform and Ed Sheeran wears
stormtrooper armor but most
interestingly Warwick Davis appears in
an Ewok costume Davis played the Ewok
wicket in Return of the Jedi when he was
still a young kid now he's in costume as
his current age suggesting this is new
and wicket the Ewok might be returning
for the rise of Skywalker along with
presumably the planet Endor think he
walks get around another clip we've seen
a lot of was revealed by director JJ
Abrams on Good Morning America last week
[Music]
I know fine so the whole gang is on a
kind of desert skiff on personna fleeing
pursuing stormtroopers whose Rovers
launched from the back end to allow the
stormtroopers to use these boosters to
chase them I love that we get some more
boat cast reaction from Chewie and that
throughout this chaos the designers
maintain the whole color scheme of green
blaster bolts from the bad guys red
blaster bolts from the good guys to help
us keep track of everything now the next
most what is the most interesting to me
titled duel it derives from the music
duel of the fates John Williams Darth
Maul theme from The Phantom Menace this
would be the final word
in the story of Skywalker now sure duel
the fates is just one of the most iconic
musical themes from the entire Star Wars
symphonic catalog but it is worth noting
that it is a prequel specific theme that
until now has only been used outside the
prequels in solo a Star Wars story
during malls cameo a past trailer
included the cryptic image of a Dark
Side ray with a mall style dual wheel
lightsaber something that we have gotten
a closer look of now that it's on
display it's also interesting how JJ
Abrams singled out mall as the one
prequel character he was most bummed to
see get killed off now to be clear the
animated series both resurrected Maul
from his apparent death on Naboo and
then later kill him off again and rebels
in a Tatooine rematch with Obi Wan set
before a new hope so Maul as we know him
is dead in the corporeal sense but so we
thought is the Emperor yet he is
returning in some way I'm just saying
with all these clues I would not be too
shocked if episode 9 pays homage to or
even resurrect small and we explained
how that could happen on a recent
episode of rogue theory go give that to
watch this promo also shows the Falcon
zipping through the innards of a space
station pursued by Tie Fighters very
similar to the run by Lando in the enum
in the Battle of Endor we also see rey
having returned to luke's island on -
now staring at the flaming wreckage of a
thai silencer maybe the same one that
she met adored in the posada footage
perhaps it's a return to the SIF cave on
that island where we see this darkside
ray and on to the next promo titled
celebrate now this promo again shows us
kylo with the Knights of Ren they're
marching through the hall that other
shots have shown poe and thin in and it
looks as though kylo is following their
dirty footsteps on the polished floor
there there's an interesting shot of
Leia clutching a lightsaber I think
that's the lightsaber of Anakin and of
course then Luke and then of course then
Rey oh wow this could be a flashback of
Luke training leia and the ways of the
force between the events of Return of
the Jedi and the force awakens something
we've all been speculating we could be
seen in this film remember Luke
presumably lost that lightsaber on Cloud
City in the Empire Strikes Back and it
didn't show up until later when Maz
Kanata had it while Luke was an exile in
the force awakens so timeline wise what
we're seeing here is either some kind of
vision or a force ghost or a cgi
recreated Leia training with Rey in a
jungle planets we'll see another shot
shows Poe dramatically piloting the
Falcon Bay
in green light perhaps from the beam of
a Death Star style super laser assuming
this is the end of the saga I think we
can expect at least some of these heroes
not to survive this war and the most
recent promo as of this taping is titled
hold on you gotta hold on or they just
like doing encouraging pop anthems
anyway this includes ray performing the
Jedi mind control trick she now uses the
hand wave used by obi-wan and qui-gon in
the past as opposed to were accidentally
using it on a stormtrooper in the force
awakens you will remove these restraints
and leave this cell with the door open
what do you think will be the most
surprising cameo or callback in the rise
of Skywalker comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA boss following the
rockstars and socials and subscribing
the rockstars on youtube and follow our
new rockstars podcast feed WikiLeaks for
early audio access to our Star Wars
updates for classic Star Wars film
rewatched series and our breakdowns of
the Mandalorian story in baby Yoda
thanks for joining me
[Music]